c'è il suo allora pronto sarei tornato
io faccia da questo però sono tornato io
le luci faccia ci siamo siete vivi siamo
vivi sono dei voti ce l'ha fatta
ricominciamo
e siamo tornati benvenuti nella nuova
puntata dello show con karim moussa dio
mio quanto mi e mancato dirlo però bando
alle ciance a luglio ho preso una
decisione voglio entrare nel mondo di
tik tok e lo so
entrare nel mondo di tik tok a 32 anni
vorrebbe dire coprirsi la stempiatura
con una parrucca lo so perché ormai li
conosco sento anche i vostri giudizi da
lontano voglio dire se mi avete dato del
boomer perché ho messo una foto di casa
mia su instagram e ho voluto prendere la
palla al balzo e fare uno dei miei
soliti diciamo esperimenti ma questo non
è soltanto un mii è salito il dark angel
kraft ma è anche un analisi
comportamentale sociologica di una delle
app più famose degli ultimi anni è pura
curiosità antropologica la mia per me e
per tutti quelli che hanno sempre
snobbato tik tok come balletti scemi per
gente scema o è molto molto più di
quello tutti i vip e le grandi aziende
usano sia per creare contenuti in
leggeri dispiace no per me sia per
mettersi in contatto con la propria
clientela
guarda inferiore siamo proprio come te
piccola parentesi questo video è
destinato ovviamente a chi tik tok non
lo conosce x men e tutti gli altri molto
probabilmente sentiranno cose ovvie e
per questo mi dispiace ma non me ne
frega comunque nulla
la prima cosa che mi ha incuriosito e il
fatto che non abbia una vera home page
come potrebbe essere uno youtube
qualsiasi ma appena la apripista parte a
mille con un video a caso come cento
questa è la categoria hashtag per te la
tua personale ponteggio che in base ai
contenuti che guardi o skippy
l'algoritmo la trasforma per adattarsi
alle tue esigenze e senza mai averla
aperta e senza neanche aver creato
l'account il primo video che ti toc mi
fa vedere è un video di alvaro vitali
che rappa vestito da pierino aiuta g
pierino ritorna un po bambino
ok lo iodio e beghe del maestro mi
conosce molto bene tutto il resto del
primo mese di utilizzo di questa app
scorre abbastanza velocemente tra trend
balletti un sacco di segni a2a b e
contenuti leggerissime la cosa che
percepisco e che sono molto fuori target
per dire c'è un sacco di relight ball
comedy su tutto cioè quel tipo di
comicità che quando tu la guardi dice
cazzo anche a me succede quando vi state
baciando e ti dice amore
vai a chiudere la porta quando mia mamma
mi chiama per dirmi che è pronto sono
fuori target di abito da solo da anni se
all'improvviso mia madre mi chiamasse
dal salotto che libica è pronto io
chiamerei la polizia
ma ovviamente essendo contenuti fatti da
giovani per giovani il contenuto non è
mai stato un problema
o almeno il tipo di contenuto non è mai
stato un problema
tu che guardi questo video
adesso indovino altro nome paolo
no quello che ho voluto capire io con
questo video è come l'algoritmo di tik
tok spinga determinati contenuti
rispetto ad altri come funzionano i like
e come funzionano le visual e se fosse
possibile partendo da zero assoluto
arrivare da qualche parte i segni più
attraenti aprile ma la cosa che più mi
ha dato fastidio come dicevo prima non è
il tipo di contenuti se che non sono per
me ma il fatto che questi contenuti
molto leggeri siano fatti in modo molto
approssimativo spesso sono piccoli
sketch visivi di pochi secondi ma
vengono fatti con una frettolosità
incredibile in quel periodo c'era un
trend cariccio per esplicare un tuo
pensiero ti mettevi in posa come
un'immagine o come la copertina di un
album e il titolo di quest'album
traduceva il tuo pensiero
giuro su dio che almeno la metà della
gente che ha fatto questo trend l'ha
girato facendo il video con il cellulare
specchiato quindi si metteva in posa ma
poi l'immagine originale era specchiata
dall'altra parte quando la prof dice di
metterti 3 se non accenni la videocamera
una cosa dovrebbe fare una quando mi
faccio il bidet concimi formula fresca
interessante c'è una categoria molto
carina chiamata hashtag lo sapevi dove
ti viene raccontato qualcosa di
potenzialmente molto interessante ma
anche di il pressapochismo uccide tutto
quanto quando scopri che homer simpson è
in coma da vent'anni e tutte le vicende
avvengono solo nella sua mente cosa no
questa è una cosa che se tu la vai a
cercare su google il 10 secondi da
smentisci l'hanno smentita anche i suoi
autori però ormai 39.000 like he coin è
impossibile tirare fuori la lingua
quando guardi in alto hashtag time for
the 21 perché spesso ci sono anche
contenuti potenzialmente molto validi
che diventano immediatamente i peggiori
di tutta la piattaforma sono quelle
persone che hanno tra le mani una storia
molto interessante ma che viene buttata
alle ortiche per mero interesse di
visual prendiamo questo ragazzo è stato
morso da uno squalo uno squalo è una
cosa poco comune soprattutto se di via
torino tremendamente interessante e
piena di domande cosa succede viene
trasformata in un trend dove ti dice
cosa è successo ma senza nessun
dettaglio
per una frazione di secondo ti fa vedere
la foto del morso
e siccome non puoi mandare indietro un
tic toc e purtroppo al volo non sei
riuscito a stoppare devi per forza farlo
finire e ripartire da capo e tentare di
bloccarlo nel momento giusto ed ogni
rewind corrisponde ad una viessmann
regalata se la stessa persona entra 50
volte in un negozio quel negozio non ha
avuto 50 clienti e quando la vecchietta
accanto a te ti dice di metterti la
mascherina e tu la zittisce con lo
sguardo
ma sei un cafone e potrei stare qui ore
a raccontare ogni aspetto grossolano di
questa piattaforma tipo che ho
finalmente beccato un tic toc hardware
di questa ragazza che fa un balletto per
il galbanino non solo con una canzone da
pelle d'oca in sottofondo
mia io ci vado
ma anche con l'immagine specchiata
galvani
quindi in quel periodo lì per non
togliermi la vita subito inizio a
pensare che tipo di contenuti creare per
tik tok la medea era quella di creare
tre tik tok per essere consistente con i
tempi e tutti e tre della stessa
categoria hashtag lo sapevi volevo
raccontare in pillole delle piccole
particolarità di torino in modo fresco e
rapido
niente di troppo complesso per non
essere fuori categoria e frasi brevi e
molto interessante ma prima devo creare
l'account ed ovviamente nome utente non
disponibile non mi lascio intimidire
grazie alla mia ventennale esperienza in
videogiochi online trova la soluzione
immediatamente mio toby con due convertì
rubin in euro ogni giorno guadagna premi
convertibili in denaro
dio è veramente un gioco online ed
eccolo 0 follower 0 video e con un
username da botta che vuole farti
vincere un milione di dollari dal tuo
zio morto
ho appena finito di girare il primo tik
tok e sto facendo una prova di montaggio
con musiche non musiche scritte non
scritte perché dopo avere analizzato
tutti i tic toc per un mese
insomma mi devo fare delle domande che
non mi sono mai fatto in vita mia
dovendo testare l'algoritmo di questo
account non ho detto niente a nessuno
per evitare che si infanga sero i dati
dell'esperimento quindi prendo coraggio
e alle 18 43 del 27 luglio carico il tic
toc delle fontane torinesi lo sapevi che
torino alle fontanelle di acqua potabile
completamente personalizzate si chiama
lotto rat e sono appunto a forma di toro
la loro costruzione e messa in posa
risale al 1862
ed allora ce ne sono circa 800
sparpagliati per tutta torino ma se
doveste avere delle difficoltà a
trovarne una
esiste un app chiamata aitor ep che le
hanno fatte e numerate una pergusa
perché perché no voglio dire e volendo
ne potete adottare uno se andate su isle
of thor act puntoit le potete adottare
uno e io l'ho fatto
questo è augusto e questo sono io che
passò del tempo con lui
quindi se voleste bere della saliva di
toro sapete dove farlo l'idea di
caricarne tre di fila era basata su una
mia previsione approssimativa fare pochi
numeri e vedere se sarebbero aumentati
mettendo più contenuti ecco diciamo che
mi sbagliavo e devo dire che quasi mi
sta dispiacendo raccontare questi
aneddoti di di torino per dei tic toc
che magari andranno anche male anzi
spero vadano male così magari faccio un
video di torino dal mio punto di vista
durante la prima ora tutto rimane fermo
nessuna visual e nessun like pochi
minuti dopo gli otto bini ha ricevuto
sette mi piace con 67 visual ok quindi
ti tocchi in teoria funziona così manda
ad un certo punto nei parte di alcune
persone il tuo video per vedere come si
comporta
gli hot obi su tik tok primissimo
commento ciao yotobi no vabbè pure su
tik tok stai seguo subito 744 visual il
green screen usato bene su tik tok che
succede 1669 visual qui c'è un
esperimento per un video sicure al cento
per cento 4.283 visual karim da tic toc
reti dico spero sia un esperimento
altrimenti significa che stai tenendo
per le tue finanze
7752 visual non vedo l'ora di vedermi il
tuo video in cui parli di tik tok e ti
lamenti del fatto che ti abbiano rubato
il nickname
è la gente mi conosce molto bene vado a
dormire con circa 8.000 visuale mi
sveglio il giorno dopo con 31mila visual
che diventano 74 mila al giorno dopo e
103 due ore dopo in realtà non ho
bisogno di caricare nessun altro tik tok
perché questo attualmente a 125mila
visual che è una cifra spropositata
non tanto per tik tok mi sa che la media
è molto più alta ma per una cosa creata
da zero e fuori di testa
nel pomeriggio arriva un commento di
alberico avevamo bisogno di te qui su
tic toc se sono quelle cose che mi fanno
scaldare il mio cuore di tuscaloosa
augurò b o anche queste verso le 163
mila viso alle 16 mila follower in 48
ore
non so se è buono era un simbolo
capisco che l'algoritmo ha sparato i
video nei per te di moltissime persone
purtroppo non potrò mai sapere quanti di
questi dati siano di persone che non mi
hanno riconosciuto e quanti di quelli
che invece mi hanno riconosciuto ma dare
un occhio alle analytics non fa mai male
che non ci sono perché ho scoperto molto
tardi che le deve attivare to
manualmente
attualmente con 300mila visualizzazioni
non ho più dati non saprò mai più nulla
del suo andamento quindi grazie mille
tic toc
quindi o aspetto ancora un po per vedere
gli analytics del primo che ho caricato
oppure mi faccio venire un'altra idea e
prendendo spunto dal commento sul green
screen
perché non fare un bel tutorial
bentornate nello scorso tik tok molti mi
hanno chiesto ma come hai fatto a fare
quel green screen ma capisco la domanda
perché i greens che infatti in
automatico con il cellulare su tik tok
sono immondizia e anche l'impostazione
diversa c'è una piccola intro è una
struttura è quasi come se fosse un mini
video più che un tic toc e come variante
disabilità anche i commenti per vedere
cosa sarebbe successo decido anche di
non guardare costantemente le
statistiche ma lasciarlo cucinare per 24
ore
allora lascio passare una settimana
senza guardare nulla e ho scoperto una
cosa molto interessante su 71 mila
visual solo il 19 per cento arriva dai
miei follower
il restante 75 arriva dai per te quindi
non tutti i miei follower vedono i tic
toc che carico ho sbagliato qualcosa io
ora è la stessa struttura di facebook
ottimo fatto sta che il secondo tik tok
per forma decisamente meno bene del
primo io ipotizzo che la struttura del
video con l'introduzione col fatto che
sia praticamente un vero e proprio video
in miniatura e che non ci siano i
sottotitoli abbia aiutato al fatto che
la gente se ne sbatte se le balle
formalmente al momento peccato
essendo una piattaforma molto immediata
bisognerebbe partire subito a bomba tipo
quando non hai nessuno che te ne ha
letti e ho stoppato lì perché non non
volevo sapere loro e quando ho deciso di
tirare le somme e finire questo piccolo
viaggio giovanile dopo 431mila visuale
31 mila follower tic toc decide di
mettere la monetizzazione è che bastardi
allora penso ad un terzo video da
caricare per vedere gli analytics anche
del guadagno della monetizzazione perché
sono molto curioso di vedere se si possa
effettivamente vivere facendo tik tok
senza vergognarsene con i genitori
perché i genitori si vergognano ma se
porta a casa i soldi ma la vita voleva
altro per me e finisco in ospedale
niente di troppo grave niente
coronavirus
mi sono beccato un'infezione alle vie
urinarie e tutto ciò mi sono fatto due
settimane
ora sto bene e sono anche riuscito ad
attivare la monetizzazione nelle
giornate del 6 7 e 8 settembre con 2008
2008 e 2700 visual ho guadagnato
rispettivamente 22 e 2 centesimi 6
centesimi
in tutto alla scrittura di questo libro
sono arrivato a 80 centesimi quindi sono
andato a comprarle l'unica cosa che
potevo permettermi alla fine usare le
tic toc è stato molto più interessante
del previsto capisco perché venga
utilizzato così tanto perché dopo un po
che usi crea assuefazione e come se
fosse un infinito barattolo di pringles
una tira l'altra e anche se sai
benissimo che ti farai del male non
riesce a smettere prima di chiudere
questo video
vorrei parlarvi di un ragazzo che ho
scoperto durante le due settimane di
ricovero in ospedale su tik tok e mi ha
intrattenuto veramente in modo che non
mai avrei pensato di scoprire in una
piattaforma del genere
lui si chiama floro ed è questo ragazzo
che fa una tipologia dei video molto
interessante per me come studio che sono
i più vi tutti penseranno a tornando
come prima è l'unica cosa che pensa la
gente ma i piombi semplicemente sono un
punto di vista il punto view fa questi
più vi che hanno dei soggetti fuori di
testa però è talmente bravo ad ad
immedesimarsi in quei personaggi che io
sono rimasto ipnotizzato
io mi sono in
corato quindi quindi per concludere
questo esperimento vorrei caricare il
terzo ed ultimo tik tok sul mio account
e sarà per forza di cose in più vi
[Musica]